the thing about metallica is when we
write we just have to follow the natural
sort of way things get put together when
we write songs and we can't sit down and
talk about how people will react to it
you can't do any of that stuff because
then it becomes premeditated and becomes
false so when we write songs we just
sort of shut the whole world off from
outsiders
[Music]
what it boils down to is that we have to
please ourselves the only thing that
that really bothers me about is when
people misinterpret things you know i
think that you know the last couple
albums we've had a very different
lyrical approach than a lot of the other
bands i hate when we get sort of thrown
in with everyone else and just
generalized you know metallica this just
like everyone else the way i look at it
is that
you can't
when you sit down and write songs and
get it together you can't worry about
how people react to it because if you
start worrying about that then you're
screwing with the basic way that you put
things together
[Music]
the thing about the metallica lyrics and
so forth and i think that so many people
react to them in different ways you know
because most of the lyrics especially on
the last couple albums are written in a
very indirect way you know which means
that different people pick up on
different things in the lyrics and i
think that you know what's interesting
is that everyone sort of reacts to them
in different ways and you know there's
always the ignorant you know people out
there that always have to blame you know
hard rock bands or actors or anything
for you know their own problems which i
mean it's basically just at the end of
the day if some of these people have
problems they should look in towards
themselves instead of pointing their
finger at rock bands or just you know
doing their own thing
what are you even looking for
madonna's music we need music
years later one of metallica songs is
getting the stranger things bump master
of puppets is back on the charts all
thanks to eddie munson's performance in
the season 4 finale
[Music]
how much of that is you playing master
of puppets it's an awesome moment
it's pretty much all of me yeah and i
kind of we we got this kind of black
belt uh kind of uh
metal guitarist to play the solo because
um that just wasn't gonna happen
but but then but i was lucky that i've
kind of played guitar since i was quite
young so i had kind of the foundations
that kind of uh take most of it
um but yeah it's great fun you know who
wouldn't want to kind of be a rock star
for an afternoon yeah
[Music]